Conditional probabilities are
probabilities associated with
a revised model that takes into
account some additional
information about the outcome of
a probabilistic experiment.
The question is how
to carry out this
revision of our model.
We will give a mathematical
definition of conditional
probabilities, but first let us
motivate this definition by
examining a simple
concrete example.
Consider a probability model
with 12 equally likely
possible outcomes, and so each
one of them has probability
equal to 1/12.
We will focus on two particular
events, event A and
B, two subsets of the
sample space.
Event A has five elements, so
its probability is 5/12, and
event B has six elements, so
it has probability 6/12.
Suppose now that someone tells
you that event B has occurred,
but tells you nothing more
about the outcome.
How should the model change?
First, those outcomes that
are outside event B
are no longer possible.
So we can either eliminate
them, as was done in this
picture, or we might keep them
in the picture but assign them
0 probability, so that
they cannot occur.
How about the outcomes
inside the event B?
So we're told that one of
these has occurred.
Now these 6 outcomes inside
the event B were equally
likely in the original model,
and there is no reason to
change their relative
probabilities.
So they should remain equally
likely in revised model as
well, so each one of them should
have now probability
1/6 since there's 6 of them.
And this is our revised
model, the
conditional probability law.
0 probability to outcomes
outside B, and probability 1/6
to each one of the outcomes that
is inside the event B.
Let us write now this
down mathematically.
We will use this notation to
describe the conditional
probability of an event A given
that some other event B
is known to have occurred.
We read this expression as
probability of A given B. So
what are these conditional
probabilities in our example?
So in the new model, where these
outcomes are equally
likely, we know that event
A can occur in
two different ways.
Each one of them has
probability 1/6.
So the probability of
event A is 2/6 which
is the same as 1/3.
How about event B. Well, B
consists of 6 possible
outcomes each with
probability 1/6.
So event B in this revised model
should have probability
equal to 1.
Of course, this is just
saying the obvious.
Given that we already know
that B has occurred, the
probability that B occurs
in this new model
should be equal to 1.
How about now, if the sample
space does not consist of
equally likely outcomes, but
instead we're given the
probabilities of different
pieces of the sample space, as
in this example.
Notice here that the
probabilities are consistent
with what was used in the
original example.
So this part of A that lies
outside B has probability
3/12, but in this case I'm
not telling you how that
probability is made up.
I'm not telling you that
it consists of 3
equally likely outcomes.
So all I'm telling you is that
the collective probability in
this region is 3/12.
The total probability of A is,
again, 5/12 as before.
The total probability of
B is 2 plus 4 equals
6/12, exactly as before.
So it's a sort of similar
situation as before.
How should we revise our
probabilities and create--
construct--
conditional probabilities
once we are told
that event B has occurred?
First, this relation
should remain true.
Once we are told that B has
occurred, then B is certain to
occur, so it should
have conditional
probability equal to 1.
How about the conditional
probability of A given that B
has occurred?
Well, we can reason
as follows.
In the original model, and if
we just look inside event B,
those outcomes that make event
A happen had a collective
probability which was 1/3 of the
total probability assigned
to B. So out of the overall
probability assigned to B, 1/3
of that probability corresponds
to outcomes in
which event A is happening.
So therefore, if I tell you that
B has occurred, I should
assign probability equal
to 1/3 that event A is
also going to happen.
So that, given that B happened,
the conditional
probability of A given B
should be equal to 1/3.
By now, we should be satisfied
that this approach is a
reasonable way of constructing
conditional probabilities.
But now let us translate our
reasoning into a formula.
So we wish to come up with a
formula that gives us the
conditional probability of an
event given another event.
The particular formula that
captures our way of thinking,
as motivated before,
is the following.
Out of the total probability
assigned to B--
which is this--
we ask the question, which
fraction of that probability
is assigned to outcomes under
which event A also happens?
So we are living inside event
B, but within that event, we
look at those outcomes for which
event A also happens.
So this is the intersection of
A and B. And we ask, out of
the total probability of B,
what fraction of that
probability is allocated to that
intersection of A with B?
So this formula, this
definition, captures our
intuition of what we did
before to construct
conditional probabilities in
our particular example.
Let us check that the definition
indeed does what
it's supposed to do.
In this example, the
probability of the
intersection was 2/12 and the
total probability of B was
6/12, which gives us 1/3, which
is the answer that we
had gotten intuitively
a little earlier.
At this point, let me also
make a comment that this
definition of conditional
probabilities makes sense only
if we do not attempt
to divide by zero.
That this, only if the event B
on which we're conditioning,
has positive probability.
If B, if an event B has 0
probability, then conditional
probabilities given B will
be left undefined.
And one final comment.
This is a definition.
It's not a theorem.
What does that mean?
It means that there is no
question whether this equality
is correct or not.
It's just a definition.
There's no issue
of correctness.
The earlier argument that we
gave was just a motivation of
the definition.
We tried to figure out what the
definition should be if we
want to have a certain intuitive
and meaningful
interpretation of the
conditional probabilities.
Let us now continue with
a simple example.